there's been an awakening have you felt
it yes even you have never faced such a
test at this time all teams give it
everything you got
no what I've seen we all need to run
you must face them
fight them
you
hey youtubers is charlie happy holidays
so there's a new Star Wars footage all
about kylo Ren's mission to face the
biggest test of his life I like the way
they're presenting this as if kylo Ren
is the protagonist of the movie he has
to defeat the evil potential future
threats as in future Jedi and if it
wasn't clear that is Adam driver
underneath that mask that's not Luke
Skywalker I've seen some people ask that
I felt that was really clear when they
were talking about their characters way
way back at comic-con but i but i guess
there's still some confusion and
actually when they went on jimmy kimmel
the other night Kimmel asked Adam driver
do we get to see you with your mask off
in Adam driver looks at JJ Abrams like I
don't I don't know if I'm allowed to say
reading between the lines of course he
wouldn't have said that if he wasn't
gonna take his mask off you just been
like no don't take the mask off I look
like that the entire movie so I don't
know necessarily that he's scarred in
the way that darth vader was scarred
like darth vader's technology kept him
alive we don't know if that's the same
thing that's going on with kylo Ren or
if he's wearing it more for show but we
do know that aunty circuses character
Supreme Leader Snoke does kind of exists
in that state he's been grievously
harmed and left very vulnerable so so he
probably has to say in some sort of
Vader type chamber but if it wasn't
clear that is who is speaking to kylo
Ren it's kind of hard to distinguish
between the voices at certain points in
the clip but it's andy serkis character
telling Adam drivers character kylo Ren
that you're going to be facing the
biggest test of your life these
characters here standing with kylo Ren
when you know when it's raining down do
look like they're special I don't know
if these are the nights of rent because
that's where kylo Ren got his name from
that's not actually his real name he
took that name later in life so I think
at some point during the movie we'll
find out why that is and we'll find out
about what happened with the Knights of
Ren why he chose the dark side of the
force this is also kind of like a dark
side teaser I know everybody's still
wondering where Luke Skywalker is
because they're like is he going to be
evil in the movie is that why they're
not showing him JJ Abrams actually
explained that them not showing him in
the marketing like the trailers the step
before the movie is a conscious choice
to tie in thematic alee with what's
going on with Luke inside the movie
itself if you guys didn't see a couple
weeks ago I posted this Luke Skywalker
video where I kind of explained what JJ
Abrams said about Luke's role in the
film in the time since Return of the
Jedi the big force users like Luke
Skywalker Darth Vader they've been
turned into ms and because a bunch of
people in the Empire
led by supreme leader snoke have formed
the first order obviously the more evil
characters control propaganda in the
galaxy so they've been selling everyone
this alternative narrative where the
Empire were the heroes of the original
trilogy Luke Skywalker was the villain
who destroyed that so you can see why
Luke might hide out after that the
entire galaxy wants his blood when you
look at Finn's character he kind of
serves as the awakening like oh my god
I've been told a lie this whole time he
awakens to the truth as well as
awakening to the force they actually
said a little bit about it at comic-con
where Adam driver was like you know
sometimes the best villains don't think
of themselves as evil even David Tennant
you know who's the the purple man during
Jessica Jones kilgrave he went on Late
Night with Seth Meyers and was talking
about how his villain doesn't think of
himself as a villain either he's like
how many villains actually think of
themselves as villains Donald Trump
doesn't think of himself as a villain
which is just like a funny David Tennant
joke but just think about that idea when
you go to see the movie kylo Ren thinks
he's doing the right thing the dark side
is the right path for the galaxy he's
not trying to subjugate people out of
malice he just feels like the Jedi have
really bad ideas and he wants to stomp
that out so here's my big question for
you guys let me know in the comments who
is your favorite character from the Star
Wars universe that's a villain that
doesn't think of themselves as a villain
about say probably Darth Vader would be
most people's pick like he does not
think he is evil oh and by the way even
though all the teaser clip still say
this film is not yet rated the film has
actually been rated pg-13 I've seen a
couple jokes that said oh well it's only
going to make 17 gajillion dollars now
really that the pg-13 vs PG rating just
allows them to push it a little bit
harder if you remember episode 3 Revenge
of the Sith was rated pg-13 so just
expect something on par with that in
terms of violence like this the stuff
they show if you do have young children
I don't think they'll be if you do have
young children please do not deprive
them of the pleasure of seeing Star Wars
in the theater don't you know pg-13 I
think it'll be totally fine for everyone
but what's going to happen next is I'm
going to post another Jessica Jones
video to be like another block of four
episodes if you guys haven't been
watching it it is awesome you need to
check it out there's also some other
flash arrow stuff and then there's a
Shannara video that I'm going to be
doing pretty soon too so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and actually
I should say there's also some big
Doctor Strange News so I'll probably
doing a Doctor Strange videos
time during this weekend so much awesome
stuff happening this week this is like
the best holiday week ever while you
guys wait for everything to post you can
click here for the captain america civil
war trailer to watch it like 15 billion
more times and you can click here for
all the other Star Wars videos that I've
been posting thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight me me me me